we do have a disinformation problem i
would say one of the worst in the world
we're days away
from elections um
just the fact that we were able to get
um a president into power almost solely
on the the investment they put into
social media and now we're about to get
you know the son
of a former ousted dictator
back into office because we have people
believing that
you know all of the issues held against
merfink
[Music]
these nameless faceless trolls
like to point back to his father's
martial law era as a sort of golden age
of sorts you know
they frame it as some sort of
period of such dynamic uh social and
economic prosperity for the country
70 000
were imprisoned 34 000 were tortured and
over 3 000 were killed during martial
law
the same accounts that tried to frame it
as a golden age
they tried to frame these killings as
they were communists so it must have
been deserved
[Music]
i remember having to fact-check acclaim
where
the pope endorsed bong bong marcos the
pope said he is a godly man
he will bring the country back to god
things like that obviously um it's so
easy to just
plaster you know the face of
a big name
and put on a fake coat you know
if it doesn't try to make marcos look
good it will try to make robredo look
bad there is one that claims that the
robledo campaign is actively seeking
advice from the communist party of the
philippines
the prevalence of this information
really just proves
ultimately that the information
environment
is compromised and with that kind of
environment
journalists are demonized in the process
because we're seen as being negative
we're seen as being anti-government
and or you know divisive with our
critical reporting when we're obviously
just doing our jobs
[Music]
he's gotten away with claiming that he
finished at oxford but he never says he
graduated there
but a lot of graphics of his
resume still do include the
institution's name under the you know
the education section but oxford itself
has said that marcos according to their
own records did not complete his degree
for philosophy
and economics
the situation as i see it is
the declining influence of mainstream
media
coupled with the increasing power of
social media how do we defend the truth
how do we defend democracy when
it's unclear if people understand what
that is this may be the last you know
democratic elections we'll ever have and
that thought scares me not just as a
journalist but as a young filipino
[Music]